ما نتحدث عنه هنا عندما
نتحدث عن أه برج 22 الكثير من الناس
لا يعرفون حتى ما هذا تحدث إلينا
عن مكان تواجده في المنطقة فهو يتمتع بموقع
استراتيجي حوالي 350
جنديًا فقط هناك لماذا إذا نظرت إليه
هنا يا آبي، ترى إمكانية الوصول إلى العراق
وسوريا، وكانت المهمة الإستراتيجية لهذه
القاعدة هي جمع
المعلومات الاستخبارية وتدريب الأردن كما ترى،
هنا في الأردن
بينما كانوا يتسمون بالسرية نوعًا ما
بشأن هذا الأمر.  موقع تدريب استراتيجي
لهم أيضًا
لتدريب هذه القوات إلى حد كبير من
المتمردين السوريين، لقد ركزوا على رؤية
الوصول السهل إلى العراق وسوريا وكان ذلك
حاسمًا في جمع تلك المعلومات
الاستخبارية، أريد فقط التكبير هنا
قليلاً  لذا يمكنك أن ترى أن هذا هو ما
يبدو عليه من منظور جوي،
فهو يقع في وسط اللا شيء، ولهذا
السبب، حتى معظمنا الذين يعملون في الشرق
الأوسط يدركون أن هذا ليس
نوعًا من المنشأة التي نعرفها جميعًا
حقًا  ونفهم ولكن
مجرد فهم المهمة في تلك
المنطقة الهجمات على القوات الأمريكية في هذه
المنطقة منذ أكتوبر منذ أن بدأت الحرب في غزة
أكثر من 160 نعم دعونا نلقي
نظرة على بعض هؤلاء هنا أه 98 في
سوريا 66 في العراق وواحد في الأردن
إجمالي 165، وهذا حقًا
جوهر الأمر هنا، هذه هي ذروة
أسابيع وأشهر من هذه الأنواع من
الهجمات عندما ينظر بايدن إلى خياراته،
ما الذي تعتقد أنه يفكر فيه
الآن؟ هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي
يفكرون فيها.  لقد قمنا بالفعل بناءً على هذه
الهجمات بالفعل لقد ضربوا أه
مستودعات الأسلحة لقد ضربوا
منشآت عسكرية في العراق وفي سوريا
حتى أنهم قضوا على قائد إيراني في
العراق لا يبدو أنه يردع إيران، لقد
سمعتم بالفعل  يدعو
الجمهوريين في الكابيتول هيل إلى القول إن
هناك حاجة إلى إجراء أكثر عدوانية
يمكن أن يبدو وكأنه إخراج
ربما منشآت بحرية من
أشياء أخرى للحرس الثوري
والتي كان لها تأثير في
منشآتهم أيضًا ولكن
الحقيقة الحقيقية هي آبي هناك  ليست خيارات رائعة
بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة عندما
تنظر إلى هذه المنطقة، وما يجب القيام به
هو ممارسة الضغط لجعلهم
يشعرون بذلك ولكن دون التصعيد في الشرق الأوسط،
وهذا ليس
بالأمر السهل القيام به بشكل صحيح.  الآن، نعم، بالتأكيد
ليس هذا، ربما يكون هذا هو
أصعب قانون لتحقيق التوازن منذ
فترة طويلة، وقد سمعنا من وزير
الخارجية يومض يقول إن هذا هو
الأصعب في المنطقة منذ
عام 1973 والذي يخبرك بكل شيء